Speaker 1: Okay. Republican National Committee
Chair Ronna McDaniel appeared this morning on
Fox and Friends. Really weird interview.
It did not go well at all. Couple topics
were mentioned. Number one, a new ad put
out by the RNC with air generated footage.
And secondly, the topic of debates and Donald
Trump will do the first thing first and the
second thing second, although we could reverse
that order. But let's not do it either way. You
wouldn't really know. Okay. No, but we'll start
with the Deepfake thing. So the RNC put out an ad.
Painting a picture with a video of a dystopian
America under Biden. The footage is fake. It
was created by AI. It's not footage of
anything that actually took place. So.
Ronna McDaniel says it is not a deepfake, but it
is literally fake. Now, Deepfake A.I. generated
footage is fake footage. Deepfake footage is
fake, but we're just talking semantics here.
And she, with a straight face, says it's A.I.
generated, but it's not a deepfake. Maybe she
just doesn't even know what these terms mean.
Speaker 2: All right, so let's talk about what
you guys did. You immediately responded to his
roll out saying he's going to run again. He kind
of said that. Let me finish the job. You guys
roll this out and it's A.I. generated. Here's
a portion. Border agents were overrun by a
surge of 80,000 illegals yesterday evening.
Speaker 4: Closed the city of
San Francisco. This. Morning,
citing the escalating crime and fentanyl crisis.
Speaker 2: So, Rana, essentially saying that will
happen if he gets four more years. What can you
bring us to the mindset going into that, Ed?
Speaker 4: So first of all, it is generated. So
we're sharing that that upfront ethically. So
it's not a deepfake. Every single image was A.I.,
but we are painting a picture of a future bite.
Speaker 1: And so it's quite literally fake. Now,
I guess what she she seems to think that if you
admit that it's fake, then it's not a deep fake.
I guess. Like, if you if you like, Hey, I'm going
to show you something fake, then it's a shallow
fake or something. But then if she were to lie
about it, then it would be a deepfake. Of course,
it seems that she doesn't even really know what
these terms mean. And it's it's worth looking at
the ad, because one of the unfortunate realities
of technology advancing the way it's advancing,
you know, the AI generated Trump arrest pictures
which were not real and all of these things is
that the worst instincts of the worst people
are now much more easily translatable into a
finished product that might pass muster. And when
you look at the video from that AI attack ad that
the RNC put out that you taken out of context,
you would have no idea that it's fake. And this
is going to be I mean, we've already looked at
the fake videos of elected officials appearing to
say things that they didn't say. This is going to
be a new layer now in political dishonesty. They
showed it. But do you have video of it? Used to be
a pretty good way of determining whether a claim
might be true at least or is true now. Hey. Yeah,
I have video of it. It increasingly isn't even
going to be the evidence we need to determine
whether something did or didn't really happen. So
arguably dangerous stuff. I don't believe that we
can stop it. I think we need to figure out how to
work with it. Then the topic of debates came up.
As we talked about earlier yesterday, Donald
Trump flipped out and said, Nobody consulted me
about doing the first debate, you know, whatever
in August or whatever, and sort of suggesting he
might not go and Steve Bannon saying Trump should
skip the all the debates altogether. Here's Ronna
McDaniel saying Trump doesn't historically shy
away from debates. And Brian KILMEADE is like,
well, actually he did skip one of our debates
and she's like, okay, fine. He did skip one.
And the entire story here for me is Ronna
McDaniel continues to lose control of the
monster that the Republican Party has created.
Speaker 2: Right. Going back to the debates,
can I ask you something? So the
Democrats don't want the top
Democrats don't want a debate with Joe on
the stage. I saw yesterday that Donald Trump
on True Social said, I see that everybody
is talking about the Republican debates,
but nobody got my approval or the approval of the
campaign. Trump can't be before announcing them.
When you're leading by seemingly insurmountable
numbers and you have hostile networks angry with
Trump, Trump and MAGA hating anchors asking
the questions why subject yourself to being
libeled and abused? So did you talk to him about
the debates? Is he in or is this just what he
does? He did this in 2016 working the refs.
Speaker 4: I talked to President Trump all
the time and we've talked to all the potential
candidates. We've let them know the schedule.
We've announced the debates. The first debate
is going to be with Fox in Milwaukee. But every
campaign and every candidate's going to have
to make a decision. Do I want to participate?
He's going to have to make that decision. I
think he'll do it. And you, President Trump,
never shies away from a debate and he
drives a debate stage in 2020 running.
Speaker 2: He does 26. He skipped
hours. He skipped hours in 2016.
Speaker 4: He did. He skipped one. But,
you know, he was in the center of the
debate stage in 2016 and he never left it. So
we'll see what happens. But we are talking to
the campaigns and the candidates. I talked to
President Trump and and Mike Patents and and
Nikki Haley. We're talking to all of them
all the time. And we'll see what happens.
Speaker 1: What does it mean that she talked to
Mike Pence, by the way, Mike Pence is Mike Pence
running? I don't even know what that. That's
kind of a weird thing to interject there. That
that is interesting. So the debate thing is
going to be interesting. As I said earlier,
if you're Trump, depending on whether DeSantis
is or isn't running the calculation as to
whether you should or shouldn't participate in
debates is a different one. Now, 20 years ago,
the idea that a presidential candidate, a
serious presidential candidate, polling well,
would not participate in debates would be almost
unheard of. But this is a Republican Party who
makes excuses for whoever it is that they want
to see elected. When it came to Trump's taxes,
there were excuses. When it came to Trump's
personal misdeeds, there were excuses. And when it
comes to Trump not debating, there will certainly
be excuses. And there were indeed as well for the
debate that Trump skipped previously. So this is
where we are at this point in time. Ronna McDaniel
has completely lost control of the party and. One
of the things about Trump talks to me regularly
is that Trump doesn't care one way or the other
what Ronna McDaniel wants. Trump sees the RNC
the way he sees everyone in his life, someone
that I might be able to use to advance what's
best for me. Or maybe not. In which case I'll just
bail and say they were disloyal and unfair and we
will move on. Ultimately, I think that Trump
is more likely to debate than not to debate,
taking into consideration everything that we know
right now. But of course, the first debate is
almost four months away and a lot can happen
between now and then. So we will follow it.